irritable bowel syndrome or IBS is a
chronic condition affecting your large
intestine
your large intestine also known as your
colon includes the cecum ascending colon
transverse colon descending colon
sigmoid colon rectum and anal canal
the muscular wall of your colon
contracts in a rhythmic fashion called
peristalsis to move the intestinal
contents toward your rectum
as it contracts your colon absorbs water
and nutrients from partially digested
food moving through it waste material
called stool is stored in the rectum
until it is expelled through the anus as
a bowel movement
with IBS the muscular contractions of
your colon are abnormal in some cases
the contractions may cause food to move
too quickly through your colon
as a result your colon does not have
enough time to absorb most of the water
from your food this condition leads to a
watery stool and diarrhea
in other cases the contractions may
cause food to move too slowly
as a result your colon absorbs too much
water from your food this condition
leads to a hardened stool and
constipation
it is unclear why your : contracts
abnormally however if you have IBS your
colon may be more sensitive to certain
factors such as stress that seem not to
affect most people other symptoms of IBS
include abdominal pain and discomfort
bloating gas and cramping
you can manage your IBS symptoms through
a combination of dietary habit changes
stress management and medications
eating food high in fiber creates softer
bulkier stools which may prevent [ __ ]
colon contractions fiber also helps
relieve constipation
stress management therapies such as
hypnotherapy and yoga may help relieve
your symptoms
your doctor may prescribe medications to
help manage your symptoms such as anti
constipation drugs to help regulate your
bowel movements antispasmodic drugs to
minimize muscle spasms and reduce pain
or sedatives and antidepressants
to relieve anxiety and elevate your mood